so the new york times thinks the u.s
flag is so 1776 so they put a group of
graphic designers together to redesign
the american flag so let's go through
some of the suggestions all right flag
number one comes with a key to
acknowledge emotions there you go do you
see fear forgiveness anger joy and pride
me either next the pentagon desi the
pentagram design how is this described
will intends to suggest interdependency
and togetherness
no but number three is quite intriguing
it represents what they call america
vagueness
i don't think we want to be more vague
that's not even a catchphrase meanwhile
number four represents america's
surrendering and its loss of ideals it
once stood for that's for every college
kid out there protesting and coloring
their hair purple i say i pass let's
move on to number five let every voice
every voice and sing lift every voice
and sing i'm not feeling it and finally
number six red white
blue or tribal signals purple
illustrates america together give me a
second
no but i don't want to lead the witness
joining me right now uh for camera
number six former white house press
secretary and author of the upcoming
book for such a time as this uh kaylee
mcananey and a woman and a guy that did
not help her at all write this book joe
concha and i'm not sure why kaylee first
off here we go again right
attacking american history my daughter
attack exactly my daughter's inside
right now coloring and i'm pretty sure
she could have made the first and the
fifth flag that you just showcased
herself but brian i mean this should be
expected the editorial board member of
the new york times said she's horrified
by the american flag you also had macy
gray say that the olympic committee
redesigning it this should be expected
but at least come up with something that
my daughter couldn't have created who is
nearly two years old right uh thank you
the 1940s last time we changed the flag
and that's because we added a couple of
states and i'm all for it alaska hawaii
you can stay joe koncha joe were you
itching to redesign the flag they say we
used to redesign our flag up until the
1900s
amazing right and this shows you brian
the ultimate disconnect between what's
supposed to be the paper of record and
sober sane people out there because this
thing is getting destroyed that this
whole story is getting destroyed on the
left and the right and look bill maher
has somehow become the voice of reason
on the left and he had the line of the
year right and and i'm paraphrasing
everybody said while the chinese are
building bridges we're arguing over what
to rename them i mean you have to expect
the times to redesign mount rushmore to
replace who's on there roosevelt lincoln
washington
and jefferson with stacey abrams aoc
taylor swift and rachel maddow it's
incredible and next thing you know we're
going to see changes now to columbus day
they're going to call it indigenous
people's day all right
that already happened or we're going to
see schools with washington and lincoln
on them to be changed because one was
only led by the guy who you know led the
charge to win the independence of
america while the other freed the slaves
all right that happened too in san
francisco there's a vote actually to do
that it's why the national anthem is
played not only at nfl games the normal
national anthem we have but the black
national anthem because that's not
divisive or anything so yeah this is
where we are at this point and the new
york times only does this i would love
to say for clicks or ratings but it
really is divisive there's only one
one other way to put it and foolish for
that matter yeah joe thanks so much and
kaylee let's look at this together uh is
this a good move the president united
states we understand has arrived at the
congressional baseball game he's got a
lot to discuss he wants to be center of
attention he doesn't want to talk about
afghanistan politically is this a good
move for him to show up there tonight
yeah but i think this is something you
do in the swamp and you think it carries
a lot of weight when it actually does
not this is mr unity he said it six to
eight times in his inauguration speech
he uh you know for the first few months
looked like mr unity but then what
happened well afghanistan fell uh
inflation you name it uh this is him
trying to become mr unity not working
all right we'll see what happens so far
democrats are out in front early kaylee
and joe thanks so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else